fac oeuvres monumentales qui sont de
plus en plus grande au fur et à mesure
qu'elles sont disposées le long de cette
demie spirale qui s'élève cette à
l'intention initiale de l'artiste la
première s'intitule
l'éveil l'évêque du monde la naissance
en fait sa figure
l'éveil la naissance de la vie sur terre
la vie animale avec la sa silhouette du
poisson et puis la demi humaine avec le
profil pour la cure soit un profil qui
est déjà tendue vers l'avenir
la deuxième sculpture s'appelle
certitude des animaux la star et
c'est un regroupement de trois animaux
différents dans sorte de cercle au
protecteur c'est l'instinct grégaire des
animaux et c'est un stack non pas les
hommes entre eux les animaux se
regroupent les hommes se séparent plus
tôt c'est un petit peu le
dessous des cartes pourquoi j'ai
toulouse et à la vertu de cet instinct
grégaire l'homme lui et c'est le sens de
la troisième sculpture part à la
découverte
ça s'appelle reconnaissance des
découvertes l'homme apprend à se
connaître
l'homme va vers son avenir l'homme va
vers la découverte de la technique des
technologies de ce qui va permettre de
lui amélioré la vie de lui faciliter la
vie sur terre et on voit sur cette
sculpture dans
l'avant à la forme d'une étrave de
bateaux l'homme qui part à la découverte
de son de son avenir
et puis la quatrième sculpture quelques
temps ce sont quelques siècles se sont
écoulés la 4e sculpture s'appelle l'âge
atomique
l'événement contemporain c'est le grand
bouleversement du milieu femmes du
milieu du xxème siècle la découverte de
l'atome l'utilisation de l'atome dans ce
que l'atom peut avoir de plutôt
favorables et de plutôt bons dans les
aides dans les dents les dans les
technologies humaines
et puis dans ce qui peut avoir de
terribles comme arme de guerre
l'atom on pense aussitôt à la bombe
atomique
et puis après cette rupture
l'émergence de l'atome on arrive sur la
5eme sculpture la fin du cycle pour
roger toulouse seilh très schématiser à
la fin du cycle ça s'appelle les
magiciens d'étendues d'herbe l'avenir et
on voit ce grand totem dressé
fier de lui sûr de lui sur de son
pouvoir
il est tout puissant il représente l'un
d'eux tout puissant mais en même temps
cet homme là roger 2 avec le titre
l'avenir se demande ce que ce qu'il veut
faire de ce pouvoir dans l'avenir
est-ce qu'il va le mettre au service du
bien au service du mal c'est toute la
question qui est posée et avec la forme
de cette de ce totem où on le voit les
bras croisés est ce que il est ce qu'il
est là comme un obstacle pour barrer la
route au lendemain et donc est ce qui a
plus d'avenir
ou est-ce qu'au contraire avec les bras
il montre un avenir possible ils montent
à chemin ils montrent une autre voie
pour aller vers autre chose c'est un
petit peu et c'est tout le cet ensemble
là est résumé par le titre générique de
l'oeuvre s'appelle la volonté humaine
est ce que l'homme
va conserver la volonté de son destin de
son avenir est ce qu'il aura la volonté
d'aller au delà de ce à quoi on est
arrivé aujourd'hui fort